And if you love learning English with your favorite movies
like Harry Potter, then be sure to hit that subscribe button
and the bell down below because every week we help you to
understand fast native speech without getting lost,
without missing the jokes, and without subtitles.
So you definitely do not want to miss a single new lesson!
By the way, do you ever feel lost when we natives speak
fast like this? It’s frustrating, isn’t it? We cut some words.
We connect others. Some sounds even morph or disappear
all together! It’s nothing like you were taught in school.
But guess what? It is possible for you to confidently
understand natives, no matter how fast we speak!
And this is exactly why in our Fluent with Friends course we take
you outside of the classroom and help you to learn English
as it is really spoken, and have a ton of fun doing it with
Friends, which various academic studies show
is the best TV series out there for learning English.
Can you imagine being able to understand English
as effortlessly as you understand your
native language?  Well you CAN, and guess what?
You can even try it absolutely free with our 3-part
masterclass! So learn more and sign up
by clicking up here or down in the description below now.
What is your favorite scene from Harry Potter? Let
me know down in the comments below,
and we might just make a lesson with it! Aww yeah
Do you love Harry Potter? Then don’t miss this lesson where you can learn about
the rules of the magical game of Quidditch in English! Let’s watch a clip from that now.